[Music]
Everyone watching TV like that
Hello Hello!
As I
said last time,
I also wanted to have a picnic with my Pokemon,
so I bought some ingredients for sandwiches.
Thank you for all the predictions and comments.It
seems that everyone in the world has taken on the challenge.
Mr. New
Trainer Could it be Pikachu
?  Wait for me I won't show you the correct answer yet It
would be a waste if I showed it right away
But it's everyone's
Music]
My super cute and dependable buddy I
knew I
was going to get pregnant
Review the hints again It
's
not screenshot time for everyone Burn it into a
folder in your brain ー
[Music] This part
that looks like an eyeball is
actually a bumpy face  It's here, isn't it cute? It
stretches and shrinks and develops in your stomach
.
[Applause]
[Music]
There were a lot of comments
asking me to teach you anything this time.
Well
, for those of you who are just starting out, I'll introduce myself as Babaan.
Also active as a type gym leader
I'm unfolding a battle with Mr. Challenger--
You too
, please give me a thrilling battle that my fans can enjoy
Bilibili won't even challenge me to the provincial fermentation city
I'll
always collaborate with
you That's why you  Medama wo Elekilet
Electrical Stream Nani
Nachamo Deshita Again
[music]